let's go next to our caller - from the
two one three area code who's calling
today from two one three hello David
yes David yes baby can you hear me you
know I can I'm hearing myself on either
a some kind of Bluetooth device or
speaker so it seems like our connection
is not the best what we can hear you you
are on live right now great a longtime
listener first-time caller
my name is David calling from Oakland I
do have some concerns about Bernie
Sanders medicare-for-all rollout okay
although I'm a really big fan of Bernie
Sanders I've been following him since
2014 big a fan as anybody I've donated
multiple times I just I have a concern
about his rollout which is not being
addressed and I've reached out to his
campaign on multiple occasions and I've
still not gotten any sort of answer well
I'm not surprised about that a campaigns
are often unable to respond down't in
ten years oh dear every year so it's
gonna go from 65 to 55 in year one fifty
five forty five year two cetera yep me
being my age I'm 36 years old that would
assume that I will not covered by
Medicare for all four three years
however my assumption is that the tax
increase will take everyone and you're
one you have this dawns on you do you do
you follow this logic yes it has the
idea is that there are people who are
going to start paying into Medicare for
all right away but they won't get the
plan
listen something's going completely
crazy with your phone so I'm just going
to let you go that's it's unbearable
it's unbearable what's going on so
listen I I recall seeing this in the
plan I believe that there is a a bridge
solution there where during that period
you are
you know I I don't remember how Bernie
Sanders addresses that in his plan but I
recall that he does and let's look into
it together and see if we can get it
figured out thank you